Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the African's language.
A couple of weeks ago I released a video
on the Dutch language,
which you can find right here.
This is kind of a followup to that video
because Afrikaans is a descendant of
Dutch.
That means that just like Dutch
Afrikaans is a west Germanic language.
Afrikaans has a total of about 7.1
million native speakers with 6.8
5 million of those in South Africa and
that's about 13.5%
of the South African population that
makes it the third most widely spoken
language in South Africa and it's the
majority language in the western half of
the country.
That means Northern Cape and Western
Cape provinces.
It's the native language of about 61% of
white South Africans and it's the native
language of more than three quarters of
quote unquote colored South Africans,
about 3.4
million people in South Africa.
The term colored,
it means people love mixed racial
background.
I didn't choose that term myself.
It's also the native language of 4.6%
of Asian South Africans.
It's also the native language of 1.5%
of black South Africans.
That's about 600,000
people and there are 10 to 15000002nd
language speakers in South Africa in
Namibia.
It's the native language of 10 or 11% of
people,
including 60% of the white population.
It's also widely used as a Lingua Franca
and most people can speak it as a second
or third language.
So how did the story of Afrikaans Begin?
Dutch speaking settlers arrived in
southern Africa in the year 1652 when
the Dutch east India company set up a
resupply station at Cape Town for its
ships travelling to the Indian
subcontinent and to Southeast Asia.
Their goal was to get fresh water,
food,
and other supplies for their long sea
journeys.
When the local [inaudible] people,
people who speak [inaudible] Sawn
languages,
we're unwilling to meet the trade
demands of the Dutch east India company.
The company drove them out of the area,
into the inland and replaced them with
European settlers and with slaves from
other parts of Africa.
Most of the farmers who were known as
borrowers were former laborers of the
Dutch east India company,
and most of them were Dutch,
but some of them were French or German,
too upset with the conditions placed
upon them by the Dutch east India
company.
The European settlers began expanding
inland so they could farm outside of the
area controlled by the company.
The Dutch east India company wanted to
prevent this inland expansion,
so they outlawed the expansion and did
European immigration and increased the
number of slaves.
Instead,
some of the slaves were brought from the
Indian subcontinent and from present day
Malaysia and Indonesia,
Britain's seized control of the Cape
Colony in 1815 and began to import
British settlers.
The British eventually took steps to
eliminate slavery and to put heavy
restrictions on the border of farmers.
Large numbers of bowlers migrated
further inland to escape British rule
setting up their own communities and
encountering various native African
communities along the way.
After a series of conflicts with the
British called the bowral wars,
South Africa became a unified British
colony until its independence in 1961
but this is lang focus.
We're supposed to focus on languages.
Why is all this history important?
Well,
it's to help you imagine the conditions
under which the language spoken by those
Dutch settlers changed and eventually
became Afrikaans.
Exactly.
How Africans developed is a highly
debated subject with some people
insisting that it's a natural direct
descendant of Dutch.
While other people insist that it's
actually a creole language that arose
when slaves and laborers attempted to
learn Dutch.
If you're not sure what creole languages
are,
you can have a look at my video on
pigeon and Creole languages right here.
Nobody knows exactly what processes
caused Afrikaans to develop,
but it's unlikely that either of those
two theories is 100% true.
In the early years of the Cape Colony,
there was a continuous stream of Dutch
speaking immigrants as well as other
Europeans who learn Dutch as a second
language.
There were also many local speakers of
[inaudible] languages who learned Dutch
as a second language and there were also
African and Asian slaves who learned
Dutch as a second language.
Local Africans and slaves most likely
spoke a Dutch based pigeon language at
some point.
Typically a creole language arises when
a pidgin language becomes the native
language of the next generation,
usually without a lot of influence from
speakers of the original standard
language.
For example,
slave owners or colonial settlers,
but in the case of Africans,
there was always extensive contact with
native speakers of Dutch,
more specifically the emerging dialect
called Cape Dutch.
On top of that standard Dutch and not
Cape Dutch was the language that was
taught in schools.
Both of these factors would help.
Cape Dutch remain relatively similar to
standard Dutch,
so even if Afrikaans is a creole
language,
it's more like a partial creole or a
semi creole language to creole languages
that I'm familiar with.
Our top pcn and be slammer which are
spoken in Melanesia and they are
english-based creoles.
Both of those languages consist of
mainly English vocabulary,
but with the syntax,
grammar and phonology of an oceanic
language.
They're essentially new languages that
got their vocabulary from English,
but Afrikaans is not like that.
It's grammar became simplified,
but the syntax of the language is
basically the same as Dutch and it's
phonology is also close to Dutch.
So it seems that Africans developed from
a form of Dutch that was influenced by
second language speakers rather than a
completely new creole language featuring
Dutch vocabulary.
That's my personal assessment,
but I'm sure some people will disagree
and that's fine.
Africans continued to develop until it
was legally recognized as its own
language in 1925 so how was Afrikaans
different from Dutch lone words?
The vocabulary of Africans was
influenced by the various languages that
it came in contact with.
For example,
Molay,
the word meaning almost comes from the
Malay word hum being the word bio
meaning much comes from the Malay Word
Been Yak Portuguese.
The word combat meaning blanket comes
from the Portuguese word.
Who would the word cuddle?
Meaning Catalan closure comes from the
Portuguese word.
Cool.
How we have a similar word,
corral and English cohesin languages.
The words for a lot of things in the
local African environment came from
Khoisan languages.
For example,
plants and animals.
This animal is called a Kudu.
Good Dude.
But the overwhelming majority of
Africans vocabulary is Dutch,
more than 90% or as high as 95%
spelling.
Africans underwent some spelling
simplifications to make the written
language more reflective of the spoken
language.
I won't mention all of the changes,
but here are some examples.
The Dutch diagraph Ij pronounced,
I became just a y in Afrikaans.
So we have the Dutch word could ice,
which is spelled like this in Africans,
but Dutch words ending with Lij,
k pronounced as Lik are spelled l I K
and Africans.
And that's a more accurate reflection of
the real pronunciation.
Lay Look.
Lilach Dutch t I o n became Sio iom in
Africans.
So we have the Dutch word not show now
and this became the spelling and
Africans,
these Dutch diphthongs,
which are actually pronounced
identically by many Dutch speakers,
all became spelled,
oh you in Afrikaans.
So the Dutch words and though are
spelled like this in Afrikaans,
though,
there are also some other spelling
changes that represent new
pronunciations and Africans,
for example,
Afrikaans merged the Dutch consonants,Z
and s two a single celled spelt s so the
Dutch word became so in Afrikaans,
a similar phonetic change can also be
found in the northern Netherlands,
but it's not represented in writing only
in speech.
Afrikaans also merged together.
The Dutch sounds represented by c h and
g to a single sound spelled g and again
a similar emerging also happened in the
Netherlands,
but not in spelling,
only in sound in Afrikaans.
When the g sound is proceeded by an
estimate as written as sk.
So we have the Dutch word soul and the
Africans word school between two vowels.
The Dutch g and V consonants are omitted
in Africans.
Look at these Dutch words,
oh,
hood that Ethan,
and now the Afrikaans equivalents the
end.
Notice that the second vowel requires a
diacritic so that we know to pronounce
these as two separate vowels and not as
one diphthong.
There are many more spelling changes,
but those are a few examples to give you
a sense of how things changed.
Verbs,
the verb system and Afrikaans is quite
simple compared to Dutch.
First of all,
the simple past isn't used except for
eight basic verbs for all other verbs.
The perfect tense is used instead,
which is also a possible in Dutch too.
So here's the Dutch sentence,
meaning I watched a cake and now here's
the African sentence pack.
It's a cake.
So notice that we use the perfect tense
in Afrikaans because there is no past
tense.
But this African sentence is similar to
the Dutch perfect 10th sentence.
[inaudible].
But notice that the way the past
participle is formed is a little
different.
Also notice that the form of the verb
for have is different.
These are both the present tense form of
the verb,
meaning to have the one in Dutchess
conjugated for first person singular,
but Africans verbs don't change
according to person or a number.
So the Dutch verb will change and other
sentences.
But in Afrikaans it will always be hate.
There was also no plu perfect tents in
Africans who perfect is like had watched
instead.
The perfect form would be used.
So let's just jump into a few more
examples,
sentences and look at these differences
as well as some others.
The next sentences mean I talked to my
children in Dutch.
You kept mets men getting it into grouts
and an Afrikaans.
I could fit my goodness.
First of all,
notice the difference in personal
pronouns in Dutch and an Afrikaans and
then notice the different forms of the
verb meaning to have the next word met
means width.
And next we can see that the possessive
pronouns are different in Dutch and an
Afrikaans May.
Next is the word for children,
but notice that the plural form is
different.
Notice that the word order is exactly
the same and that the second verb goes
at the end in Afrikaans,
which is the same as in Dutch and also
the same as in German.
The next sentences mean did you have a
good new year?
First in Dutch have gi hooten,
new hub and an Afrikaans and English.
It's like have you a good new year?
Head again.
We see the different forms of the verb
meaning to have.
Then we see the different spelling of
the personal pronoun.
Yeah,
Yay.
Meaning you.
Then we have the indefinite article,
which has been shortened in Afrikaans.
Then notice that the word for good is
slightly different.
Then after that,
notice the slight difference in the
words for a new year.
And finally the past participle of the
verb meaning to have is the same in both
sentences.
Now let's look at a similar sentence,
but with a little change.
This one means did he have a good new
year in Dutch?
Hey Cy,
a hoot,
new Yamaha and an Afrikaans.
Look at the first word and notice that
the Dutch verb conjugation changes.
This is the third person singular form
of the verb.
The verb form stays the same in
Afrikaans and next we see that the
personal pronoun,
high e meaning he is spelled
differently.
After that,
the rest of the words are the same as in
the sentence is up above.
The next sentences mean we will live.
We will die in Dutch,
Missoula,
Lavan,
Zilla,
Stephan,
and in Afrikaans on Saul starbuck.
Notice here that the subject Pronoun for
week is different in Dutch,
the subject pronouns as va,
but the object pronoun similar to us in
English,
his aunts in Africans owns is both the
subject and the object Pronoun.
Next,
notice that the future tense in Dutch is
formed using Xulane plus the infinitive
in Afrikaans.
It's formed by using sal plus the verb
and there really isn't an infinitive and
Afrikaans,
so there's just one single verb form.
This part here is the same as the
present tense form,
so we can see that there are some
differences between Dutch and Africans,
but generally the vocabulary is very
similar and probably very easy to
recognize.
Once you're aware of those general
differences and the word order is
basically the same.
So how well can Dutch speakers and
African speakers understand each other?
The answer to this question depends on
who you ask,
but generally they seem to be mutually
intelligible to a moderate level.
With African speakers being able to
understand the Dutch better than Dutch
speakers can understand.
Afrikaans,
there are a couple of important factors
and intelligibility.
One of them is accent.
I've heard from a few Dutch people and
from a few Africans people that they can
understand certain speakers of the other
language very well but other speakers
are a partner to understand and that
might be because certain Dutch dialects
have pronunciation that is more similar
to Africans than others and there are
also a lot of second language speakers
of Afrikaans who's accent might be
difficult for native Dutch speakers to
understand.
Another factor is register register
means the level of formality used.
Now if the speakers of both languages
use the standard formal variety of their
language and they don't use any local
variations or slang,
then they'll probably understand each
other much better.
Formal speech basically resembles the
written language and the speakers of
either language can basically understand
the other one when it's written.
A common question that I see written on
the Internet is should I learn Afrikaans
before learning Dutch?
Would that help me to learn Dutch later
on?
I would say that that's probably a bad
idea to learn afrikaans just because you
want to learn Dutch later,
it's probably would end up confusing you
when you learn Dutch later on because
Dutch is similar to Africans,
but more complex.
I would say that the best reason to
learn Afrikaans would be because you
have a deep cultural interest in South
Africa and you want to spend some time
in that country or in Namibia.
So the question of the day for speakers
of Africans and Dutch,
how well can you guys understand each
other?
Leave your comments and your experiences
down below.
And for everyone else,
I don't have a question of the day.
So why don't you ask a question to the
Africans and Dutch speakers?
That sounds good.
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And I want to say thanks to all of my
patrion supporters for continuing to
make Lang focus possible.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.